and and so what happens is we all just
become this undifferentiated androgynous
consumer that's always all we are now is
is I don't want to sound like a commie
or something but this is being pushed
not just by the leftist activist it's
being pushed by the entire liberal
establishment and by Corporate America
and the whole power structure which is
just to take away all the ornamentation
all the differentiation all the natural
lovely diversity of life and make us all
just a bunch of blobs to buy a bunch of
hormones and purchase their products and
uniform actually means the same one form
that's what uniform is for is to make
all the same so they're stripping away
the Communist sameness of everything to
create a weird world to then reconfigure
it so that everyone yeah instead of
having different kinds of uniforms in
different areas of life are different
for men and women now it's literally we
will just be uniform undifferentiated
blobs plugged into our computers and
living in in the metaverse and eating
ice